McDonald's is selling its business in Russia in response to the war in Ukraine.
Burger chain said it wasn't consistent with its values to continue operating there.
McDonald's temporarily closed all its Russian outlets in March.
The BBC's Russian editor Steve Rosenberg says...
…it's very much the end of an era.
Well, McDonald's had temporarily shut its restaurants across Russia back in March.
That's when a lot of international companies and global brands...
…had suspended their operations.
The fact that McDonald's has now come out and said,...
…"look, that's it, we're selling up, we're pulling out."
I think that is recognition of the reality, really,...
…that things are not going to return to normal here,...
…that what the Kremlin calls its "special military operation",...
…what most of the world calls Russia's war,...
…has changed things long term.
So, McDonald's issued a statement in which it said that,...
…owning a business in Russia was no longer tenable...
...or consistent with McDonald's values.
Now, this really is the end of an era.
I remember when the first McDonald's restaurant opened in Russia,...
…way back in 1990, back in the USSR.
There was such excitement, such huge crowds.
I had to queue for three hours to get in.
And I remember that day, American burgers and fries and pies,...
…they really were a symbol that day,...
…of Moscow embracing the West, you know,...
…fast hot food to help end the Cold War.
But fast forward 32 years, things have changed.
And basically Russia and the West have lost their appetite for one another,...
…because Russia's offensive in Ukraine,...
…has sparked international condemnation and sanctions,...
…and the Kremlin accuses the West of threatening Russia.